One of my biggest revenue generators is my clothing line.
And it wasn't until my followers on Facebook, actually...
...this was like, three years ago,...
...they asked me if I could make a t-shirt for them.
And it was only then that I actually went out to Forever 21,...
...bought some blank t-shirts, made a design on Adobe Illustrator,...
...got it locally printed and sold my first 20 or 30 shirts.
And then they asked for more.
So, interestingly enough, even though I've always wanted to be a fashion designer and everything,...
...the idea of merging fashion with Blogilates and fitness came from my fans.
As long as my ears are open,...
...and I'm open to changing and creating new things for them constantly,...
...then it's a beautiful relationship.